The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ERIK DEMAINE: All right, welcome
back to Dynamic Optimality.
This is the second
of two lectures.
And today we're going to
focus mainly on lower bounds.
So last time we saw this
geometric connection
to binary search trees.
So again, this is about is there
one best binary search tree.
And we represented binary
search trees, or at least
the execution of
those algorithms,
as point sets in time space.
And of course a point
set corresponded
to a valid execution of a BST
tree where each of these points
represented which nodes got
touched during an access.
If and only if the point
set was arborally satisfied,
meaning you take any two
points in the point set,
if they span a
rectangle that is not
just a horizontal or
vertical line segment,
there must be a
third point somewhere
inside that rectangle,
which in the end
implies that there's a monotone
path between those two points.
And then we saw, on
the upper bound side,
we saw a greedy algorithm, which
was the obvious offline thing
to do, which is as
these points come along,
as you do the accesses,
the white dots,
you add the necessary
red dots in order
to make it arborally
satisfied row by row.
And so that seemed like the
obvious offline thing to do.
Turns out it could be done
online up to constant factors.
I sketched that last time.
And this is conjectured to
be within a constant factor
of optimal.
We can't prove it.
What I'm going to show
today is our best attempts
at proving this is optimal.
In particular, there's
something called
the signed greedy algorithm,
which is almost the same as
greedy, but it's a lower bound.
And greedy is an upper bound.
So all you need to do is
show these two things are
within a constant factor of
each other and we're done.
We're not going to
get there, obviously,
because we haven't
solved that yet.
But along the way,
we're going to see
tango trees, which achieve this
log log n competitive bound.
So we think greedy is
constant competitive.
The best we know right
now is log log n,
this is an improvement
over red black trees,
which achieve log n.
Any balance binary search
tree is within a log n
factor of optimal.
So it's all between constant and
log n that we're trying to do.
Another fun consequence
of lower bounds
is a particular
sense in which log n
is necessary for some
access sequences.
So I argued last time
that if you take, like,
a random access sequence, or--
for example, if you look
at a binary search tree
and you say, oh, I'll just
access the thing that's
deepest in the
tree, there's always
something that's deep in the
tree of depth, at least log n.
And so for any
binary search tree
there is an access sequence.
No matter what that
binary search tree does,
I can choose the next
access to force you
to take log n per operation.
What we're going to see
today in these lower bounds
is one access sequence that
for all binary search trees,
they must spend log n time.
Just changing the
quantifiers around.
So instead of for every
binary search tree
there is an access
sequence, there's
going to be there is
an access sequence
such that for every
binary search tree
you need log n time.
That's something we'll get
easily out of these lower
bounds.
So let's jump into
the lower bounds.
And we're going to cover you
could say three different lower
bounds.
The independent rectangles
is kind of a generic class
of lower bounds.
Then we're going to see
two specific choices
of these independent
rectangles, which are actually
older than this
result. So this is
sort of a modern interpretation
of two older results
and a more general result.
Signed greedy is going to turn
out to be the best lower bound.
Is It's better than all the
ones that we will cover,
but each of them has their
own uses for analysis.
Each of them is going to
let us analyze an algorithm
that we couldn't or
that we don't otherwise
know how to analyze.
So let's do the independent
rectangle lower bound.
The sort of generic one.
So these lower
bounds are all going
to refer to the
original point set,
the white dots, the accesses.
The idea is you're given an
access sequence, a sequence x
i-- x 1 up to x n, and you
want to know some lower bound
that every binary
search tree requires
a certain number of accesses, a
certain number of node touches
for that access sequence.
You know it's at least n.
You want something
bigger than n.
We've got to at least touch the
nodes that are being accessed.
I'm going to drop this.
So I want the notion of
independent rectangles.
And general idea of
dependent rectangles
would be something like this.
Ah, I see.
So these are two rectangles.
I consider them dependent
because one of the corners
is inside the other rectangle.
This is true no matter
where the points are.
So, for example, if I take two
points, they span a rectangle.
If I take these two points, for
example, they span a rectangle.
This corner is inside that one.
So these are considered
dependent rectangles
in either case.
So corner here does not
necessarily mean a point--
any of the four corners.
Rectangle is defined
by two points,
but it has all four corners.
And so, in particular,
independent rectangles--
for example, they might
be completely disjoint.
Those are going
to be independent.
Something like that
is independent.
But there are some other cases.
You can have rectangles
that look like this.
OK?
And it doesn't matter
where the points are.
Maybe here, here,
here, and here.
Or the other way.
These are independent.
And there's one other kind of
special case, which maybe I'll
use color to draw the
other one because they're
right on top of each other.
So I've got a point here, a
point here, and a point here.
These are two rectangles
defined on three points.
So they both use this point.
And if you check, it does
satisfy this condition.
So no corner strictly
inside the other.
But we also need that the
rectangles are unsatisfied.
So this is saying that
there's no other point even
on the boundary
of the rectangle.
So this part says, OK, there's
nothing strictly inside.
But we also need
that on the boundary
there's no other points.
So this is the only
sort of situation other
than reflections where
you get this working
out as independent.
AUDIENCE: Last case
is independent?
ERIK DEMAINE: Last
case is independent.
All right?
So this is a definition.
If I give you a
set of rectangles,
they're independent.
I mean, I was
looking at pairwise.
But if they're are
pairwise independent,
then they will be independent.
No corner of any
rectangle strictly
inside any other rectangle.
And there's no points
of those rectangles
that are inside others.
OK.
Cool.
So what?
Lower bound says the optimal
offline binary search
tree, or the optimal way to add
dots to satisfy your point set,
is going to be at least
the size of the input--
meaning the number of
initial points you have--
plus half the maximum number
of independent rectangles.
OK.
So this is a max
independence set problem.
In general, that's NP-complete.
Turns out we'll be able to at
least approximate the number
of independent rectangles
within a constant factor
by the end of class.
That's going to
be signed greedy.
So signed greedy is
going to be the best
way up to constant factors to
choose independent rectangles.
For now, someone
magically tells you
what's the best way or you
just choose some reasonable--
any choice of
independent rectangles
will be a lower bound.
But you get the best lower
bound by choosing the max.
OK?
So we're going to
prove this theorem,
and then we're going to see
three different ways to choose
those independent rectangles.
And we'll use them
for various things.
Wilber 1, Wilber,
2 and signed greedy
are going to be
the three choices
for independent rectangles.
All right.
To prove this theorem, we're
going to change it a little bit
first.
And this is kind of
the focus of today--
is the idea of
signed rectangles.
If you look at the rectangles
in the world spanned
by two points, there
are two different kinds.
There's the top right,
lower left kind.
And then there's the top
left, lower right kind.
These are positive
slope or negative slope.
Those are the two
kinds of rectangles.
And it's helpful to think about
just the positive rectangles
or the slash rectangles and
just the backslash rectangles
separately.
So we're going to
call a point set--
it's a little hard
to pronounce--
we used to call
this plus satisfied.
So maybe it's easiest
to pronounce it
that way, the symbol formerly
known as plus satisfied,
if all plus rectangles
that are not
on a horizontal or vertical
line contain another point.
So a point set is
arborally satisfied
if and only if it is plus
satisfied and minus satisfied--
just breaking apart that
definition into two parts.
But now, we're going to look
at point sets that are just
plus satisfied or point sets
that are just minus satisfied.
And then we can look
at the optimal solution
if you only care
about plus rectangles.
So this is the smallest
plus satisfied point set
containing all the access
points, all the given points.
So we'll call that the input.
OPT was the smallest
arborally satisfied.
OPT plus is the--
you just look at
plus rectangles.
OK.
Why are we doing this?
Well, for now, we're going to
do it to prove this theorem.
So lemma, which was what
we're actually going to prove,
is if you look at
this OPT plus thing,
it's got to be at least
the size of the input--
everything has to at
least contain the input--
plus maximum number of
independent plus rectangles.
So this is where we're
actually going to prove.
If you want to
get plus satisfied
and you've got k
independent plus rectangles,
you need to add at
least that many points--
so at least one point
per plus rectangle.
If you can prove this,
you prove the theorem
because this holds
for minus just
as well as plus by symmetry.
And so you take your maximum
independent set of rectangles.
At least half of them are
plus or at least half of them
are minus.
You apply this bound, and that's
where you get the 1/2 here.
So this is stronger, I
guess, than the theorem,
and this is what we're
actually going to prove.
And so, in this
world, we just are
thinking about plus rectangles,
which is a little weird.
But it works.
And the proof is going
to be in three steps.
I'm first going to give you
an overview of the steps,
and then we'll actually do them.
So this is like a
two-level proof.
First thing we
do, the top level,
is we're going to
find a rectangle
in the independent
set, and we're
going to find a vertical line
that hits only that rectangle.
So we're going to
have some rectangle
in the independent set, and we
want a vertical line stabbing
it such that no
other rectangle is
stabbed by this vertical line.
So all other rectangles--
that's independence,
so maybe they look
something like this--
but nothing like this.
Not obvious that such a
thing exists, but it does.
Actually, not that hard to find.
We just need some
rectangle with some line.
Then, using that
property, we're going
to be able to find some points
in that rectangle that are also
in the optimal plus
solution in the rectangle
crossing the line.
Let me get another color.
So we're going to find
a point on the left
of the line and a point
on the right of the line.
And they're
horizontally adjacent,
meaning there's no other
point between them.
So we know there's
some point in this box.
Because this is a
plus box, it has
got to be satisfied somehow.
And I claim there's
actually two points
on either side of the line.
One of them could be equal
to this or this, but not both
obviously because they're
horizontally aligned.
And then what we're going to
do is charge the rectangle
to those points.
And then, basically, we're
going to remove that rectangle
and repeat.
And the claim is this charging
sort of only happens once
per point.
And therefore, the number of
points in the optimal solution
has to be at least the
number of rectangles-- number
of plus rectangles in
the independent set.
So, basically, this is a way
of ordering the rectangles.
We're going to take one that
has one of these vertical lines,
find two points that
pay for that rectangle,
and therefore argue that OPT
has to be at least the number
of rectangles.
So we have to argue that at
least one of these points
is not one of the
original points.
And that's where we're
getting the input plus this.
So there's lots of
things to check here.
Let's do them one at a time.
And throughout, I'm
going to assume--
let me write that the bottom--
assume all x- and
y-coordinates are unique.
This is an idea I mentioned
last time as well.
If you have lots of
accesses to the same key,
imagine them being accesses
to slightly different keys.
Just skew them a little
bit, and it doesn't
change any of the bounds much.
I won't to argue that here,
but at the least think of this
as just a simplifying assumption
to make the proofs cleaner.
So how are we going
to do step one?
I need to find some rectangle
and some vertical line that
only stabs that rectangle.
And the way we're going
to do that is just
take the widest rectangle that
just has the maximum x extent.
There might be more than one,
but just take one of them.
So it's very wide.
What this tells
us is that there's
no other rectangle like this.
This would be independent,
but it would be wider.
So that's not allowed.
Now, we have to think about
all sorts of scenarios.
So we've got a point
here and a point here.
It could still be that we
have rectangles like this.
They just can't go
farther to the right.
It could be we have
rectangles that go like this--
just can't go too
far to the left.
These rectangles
that are anchored
in the lower left and
these rectangles that
are anchored in the upper
right can't touch each other
because then one of
them would be satisfied.
This one's going to
have a point down here.
This one is going to
have a point here.
I guess-- yeah, let's
see, how would it
go if they were touching?
We'd have a corner--
hmm, touching is a little weird.
Ah, I see.
Good.
This can't happen
because we assume
the x-coordinates are distinct.
So that's why I did this.
That's the reason.
So this can't happen.
And I also can't have them go
like this because then there's
a corner in the strict interior
of the other rectangle.
Is that clear?
This rectangle
can't come over here
because then that would
be not independent.
Rectangle can't come
right to the same spot
because there is no same spot.
That would be two points
on the same vertical line.
And so what we must
have is a picture more
like this where there's an
empty region in between.
that not hit by-- there can be
many of these rectangles, many
of these rectangles.
They're independent
from each other.
That's like this case here.
There can also be some
rectangles like this.
But by the same argument, these
guys can't touch each other
and they can't
overlap horizontally
because then one of the corners
would be inside the other.
Question?
AUDIENCE: For that picture,
you drew a rectangle
under the other one.
ERIK DEMAINE: This
one or this one?
AUDIENCE: That one.
ERIK DEMAINE: Yeah,
this one cannot happen.
That's what we claim--
haha, right.
So you're right.
So we worry about--
interesting.
Well, we worry about
something like this.
AUDIENCE: Sorry, why
can't that happen?
ERIK DEMAINE:
Yeah, you're right.
I actually drew
the wrong picture.
Sorry.
Kidding.
Yeah.
I really meant
line segment here.
I'm sorry.
Poor choice of wording.
So vertical line is
actually just going
to go the extent
of the rectangle--
something like this.
Sorry.
We can't forbid
rectangles like this.
What we can forbid our
rectangles like this
that also try to
cross that segment.
We'll see why this is
enough in a moment.
Sorry about that.
I really only care about the
interior of this rectangle.
I'm trying to get a vertical
line that only stabs
this rectangle, nothing else--
inside the rectangle.
Sorry, poor wording.
I don't care about
these guys outside
because I can't say
anything about them.
They could be all over the
place in an independent set.
I mean, relative to what
hits this rectangle,
there's stuff on the left.
There's stuff on the right.
There are these guys.
There can also be
things like this.
But still remaining
are these regions
which are not hit
by any rectangles,
and that's because
what I was saying.
These guys can't touch each
other because then there
would be equal x-coordinates.
They can't overlap
because then one of them
would not be independent
from the other.
So I get my vertical lines.
I just need one, but it
could be any of these.
In general, for example, if
you take all of these lower
left anchored
rectangles and take just
to the right of
the rightmost one,
that will be a valid
choice for your line.
Because you can argue none
of these can overlap it.
So that's step one.
We just take a widest rectangle.
The one thing we
needed to forbid
was something going like
this all the way across.
Step two.
Step two is actually
pretty easy.
Once you've identified
this red line--
inside the rectangle, you
know there are some points.
And I'm going to
take the rightmost.
And then among all
the rightmost points,
I'm going to take the
topmost point that
is to the left of the line
and inside the rectangle.
So let p be the topmost,
leftmost point--
sorry, rightmost-- that
is both in the rectangle
and left of the line.
Let me erase this one for
a little bit more room.
So I'm looking at
all of this region
to the left of the
line in the rectangle.
I want to take the
rightmost and then topmost
point-- something like this.
How do I know such
a point exists?
Because this point
is such a point.
And this point is to
the left of the line.
So if there's nothing else in
here, that is a valid choice.
But in general, we go to the
right as much as possible.
Then we go up as
much as possible.
So that's a point, which
we will call them p.
AUDIENCE: Couldn't it be on
the border of the rectangle?
ERIK DEMAINE: It could
be on the border.
It could be interior.
We don't know.
AUDIENCE: When you said
topmost, what is your topmost?
ERIK DEMAINE: Topmost means
of maximum y-coordinate.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
Got it.
ERIK DEMAINE: So it
could be up here.
We don't know.
First, we go rightmost.
Then, among all the
things in that column,
we go to the topmost one.
So it might be on the top.
It might not be.
These are points-- sorry,
this is a point in OPT plus.
And then q is going
to be a similar thing.
It's going to be the
bottom-most, leftmost point
in OPT plus that
is in the rectangle
and right of the line.
Not totally symmetric, though.
We're also going to
say and not below p.
So now we're looking at
this upper region here.
Among all the things
that are not below p--
should have drawn
this more horizontal--
and to the right
of the red line--
so that's up to here, I guess--
I want to take the
leftmost column that
has any points in it
and then among those
take the bottom-most
point in the column.
I claim that's actually
going to be on this line.
First thing to check is
that such a point exists.
Such a point exists
because, in particular, this
is such a point.
It is to the right of the line.
It's above the blue line,
right of the red line,
in the rectangle.
But I claim that if we take the
leftmost, bottom-most one, then
they must actually be aligned.
Why?
So if it was somewhere
else, like up here
or like this point, then I claim
that is an unsatisfied box.
Let me draw that picture,
make a little clearer.
So something like this.
So we've got our red line
and we've got this picture.
This is p, and then actually
we don't know anything
about down here.
This is q.
I claim that these black regions
cannot have any points in them
because, by definition, p
was in the rightmost column.
So there's nothing in this strip
and between p and the red line.
And it was the topmost within
the column, which means there's
nothing above p in the column.
So that's why all the
points are confined
to this region over here.
Similarly, for q, if you look
at the things that are above
or on this horizontal
line, which
was the blue line
over there, then we
know that there's nothing
in this strip in between
because q is leftmost.
And then among leftmost,
it was bottom-most,
so there's nothing down here.
So that means, if these guys
are not horizontally aligned,
there is an
unsatisfied box here.
Contradiction.
It's a plus box.
So in OPT plus, there's got
to be another point, which
was a contradiction.
So in fact, p and q must
be horizontally aligned.
So that was step two.
Finally, we get step three.
So the idea with step three--
now we're going to do
a charging argument.
We want to say, OK, basically,
for every independent
rectangle, we want to
find a point that's
in OPT that was not
in the original input.
And therefore, then
OPT plus has to be
at least the size of the
input plus 1 per each
of these plus rectangles.
So the idea is the following.
Because of all this set-up--
because we made pq
horizontally aligned--
they're inside the rectangle.
And furthermore,
they're adjacent
and they cross
this vertical line.
And that vertical line is not
crossed by any other rectangle.
When I say line, I
mean line segment.
There's no other rectangle
that hits this red thing.
Therefore, these
two points are not
going to get charged
as a pair ever again.
If you remove this rectangle,
repeat this process,
pq is never going to
get charged again.
So we charge to pq.
And the pair never
charged again, never
be charged by another
rectangle because no rectangle
hits the red thing.
So no rectangle
contains the segment pq,
the horizontal segment pq.
So this is almost what we want.
We really want a single point
which is not in the input.
So we have p and q.
They're horizontally aligned.
Now, if they're
horizontally aligned,
we know that not both of them
are in the original input
because all y-coordinates
are distinct.
This is usually true
because you're only
accessing one point
per row, per time step.
So one of these might
be in the input,
but the other one is not.
So that's the one I
want to hold onto.
And say, OK, that's a point
added to OPT plus that pays
for this rectangle.
It's not quite so
simple, though,
because we might
have a whole bunch
of horizontally-aligned things.
And one rectangle
charges to this one.
One rectangle
charges to this pair.
That's OK, though, because
here we have four points.
Again, one of them
could be in the input.
The other three
have to be added.
And so you've got three
rectangles, three added points,
and we're happy.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Just to make
the argument formal,
wouldn't you want to say that
only when your saying assume
that x and y are always
distinct-- but then,
if you have the
same either x or y--
ERIK DEMAINE: Ah, good point.
So this is distinct in
the input is what I meant.
Obviously, in OPT,
any satisfied set
is not going to
have this property.
Yeah, good.
So I want to assume x-
and y-coordinates are only
distinct in the input.
OPT will not have that property.
And that's why p and q can exist
and have the same y-coordinate.
Another question?
AUDIENCE: Does this
still [INAUDIBLE]
the special case where
your two points are
the points of the rectangle?
ERIK DEMAINE: OK.
So the question is can p and q
be the points of the rectangle?
One of them can be.
Like, p could be here, and then
another point is over here.
So then that will be the
segment that you are using,
between p and q.
Or it could be q is
here, and p is over here.
Then that's the segment.
You can't have them both
equal because p and q have
to be horizontally aligned
and also because there's got
to be another point in there.
Yeah, so that should work.
You have to check that this
boundary case is still OK.
But the claim is no other
rectangle touches this red line
even on the endpoint.
And therefore, no
other rectangle
will wholly contain p and q.
And so that means you're only
charging to this pair once.
And then this pair
charging is OK
because, luckily, there's three
edges here, four vertices.
One of those vertices
we can't charge to,
so there's exactly the right
number of things for the edges,
and we're OK.
Yeah, this can really happen.
In fact our favorite
example of the pinwheel--
if instead of doing the greedy
addition, we do this addition--
these are supposed to
be horizontally aligned.
A little hard without a grid--
a graph blackboard
would a great.
So this is not quite satisfied.
You've got to add some more
points here or something.
But it has the feature that--
here's an independent
set of rectangles.
I can do this one,
this one, and this one.
So this is three
independent rectangles.
As the white points go,
they're independent rectangles.
The corners are not
strictly inside each other,
and none of the white
points satisfies
any of the other rectangles.
And indeed, if you
applied this argument,
first you take the
widest rectangle
and say, OK, here is my
vertical red segment.
I'm going to charge to these
two guys, this segment,
and then eventually this guy
will charge to this segment
and this guy will
charge to this segment.
And luckily, there
are three added points
for exactly the three segments
for the three rectangles.
There had to be another point.
So that's a lower bound.
A lot of work--
but in the end, it
says, look, just
find an independent set of
plus boxes, plus rectangles.
That's a lower bound on OPT.
So now, the question
remains, how
do we find a good independent
set of plus boxes?
And now we'll go through
the three different ways
we know how to do it.
I'll start actually
with Wilber 2.
It's called Wilber 2 because
it was in a paper by Wilber,
and I think he called it lower
bound number 1 and lower bound
number 2.
But for pragmatic reasons, I'm
going to start with number 2.
It's from 1989, so it's
actually an old paper.
And it was sort of
lost for a long time.
I don't think Wilber
wrote any other papers.
It was in SICOMP, a big journal.
so a few years after
splay trees and then
sort of rediscovered
in the early 2000s
and turns out to be really
useful for a lot of theorems.
So here's the lower bound.
Again, we're
looking at the input
point set-- no added points,
just the original points.
Look at every point, and
look at all the points
that you can see from
this point downward.
What does see mean?
I'm interested in
points below p that when
I draw the rectangle
contain no other points.
So this is sort of
like a lower envelope.
It's going to look
something like this--
and maybe some points like this.
So all of these rectangles
have to be empty.
So these are the downward
visible points from p.
And now, among these points, you
can sort them by y-coordinate.
And I want to see
how many times do
they cross this vertical line.
So if I order them
by y-coordinate--
so I start here, and
maybe I go to here.
Then the next one is over
here, so that's across.
Then I go over here.
Then I cross.
Then I go here.
Go here, here, cross.
So if I visit them
in order, I want
to know how many times do
I cross this vertical line.
So this is the past of p,
all of the accesses before p.
Think of this is how
many times you alternate
between accessing on
the left of the line
and accessing on the
right of the line.
So count number of alternations
left or right of p.
And again, if we assume
that no key is ever
accessed more than
once, then there
will always be left or
right, never exactly on.
And then I want to
sum over all points.
And I claim this
is a lower bound.
Why is it a lower bound?
Essentially, I take each
of these red lines that
cross the p vertical line
and I turn them into a box.
So there's one there, one
there, one there, and one there.
I claim if I do this for
all p, all those boxes
will be independent.
All those rectangles will be
independent from each other.
I won't prove that formally
here, but you can check it.
So it's obvious for one
p because each of these
has a different vertical span.
If you do it for all
p-- all the points p--
these won't conflict.
So by the independent
rectangle lower bound,
this is a lower bound on
OPT up to a factor of 2.
So what?
Wilber 2 is quite interesting.
For a long time,
we've conjectured
that it is the right answer.
So conjecture-- I know
it's a weird lower
bound to even think of.
It's a very hard paper to read.
Without the geometric
view, it's even harder
to imagine the
definition of this bound.
It's sort of an algorithm.
It's a way to assign boxes.
It gives you a lower bound.
It's a little weird.
We conjecture that
it's proportional
to the optimal solution.
We can't prove it.
We've tried many times.
It's a pain to work with,
but it is what it is.
There's one theorem
that uses it,
so I want to tell you
about that theorem.
But I don't want to go
into it in too much detail.
It's a neat theorem.
And it's in a paper
by Iacono, 2002.
And it was the first paper to
revitalize the Wilber stuff.
So it's like, hey, there's
this Wilber 2 bound.
We can use it to solve a
new problem, which is called
key independent optimality.
Briefly, the idea with
key independent optimality
is, suppose you've heard
about dynamic optimality.
You know, it's really cool
because splay trees and whatnot
seem to really adapt to
whatever your inputs are.
But suppose your inputs
really don't have keys.
They're just arbitrary objects
labeled however, just randomly.
In fact, let's assume that
they're labeled randomly.
Suppose the keys are
generated randomly
because they're meaningless
or just arbitrary things.
So you figure, oh, maybe
I'll make it better
and just randomize
them completely.
If keys are random,
then dynamic OPT
is the same thing up to constant
factors as the working set
bound.
That's the theorem.
So this is cool because it
means splay trees are actually
optimal in the setting
where keys are random.
This is in expectation
over the randomized keys.
And the way this theorem
is proved is basically--
so what this is saying is,
if we take a point set--
arbitrary point set--
but then we re-randomize
the x-coordinates-- leave the
y-coordinates as they are--
then you can compute
how Wilber 2 behaves.
Because now you have
a bunch of points,
and you're randomly
shifting their x-coordinate.
So it's like if you're
randomly bouncing around an x
and you're interested
in this envelope
on the left and the right,
you want to know basically
how many times--
I guess since I last
accessed p, which is here.
We didn't do that here, but
in the working set bound
that's part of the deal.
If you look on the
left side, it's
like how many times
does the max change.
And you may know if
you n random numbers
and you want to know how many
times does the max changes
as I go left to right,
as I take larger
and larger prefixes
of those n numbers,
the answer is log
n in expectation.
Because the more points you
have, the less and less likely
it is for the max to change.
So basically, you show
the expected Wilber
2 of a point over
this randomization
is theta log ti, where ti
is the working set bound.
And so, that gives
you the theorem.
This gives you a lower bound
of the working set bound.
We have upper bounds of
the working set bound,
and therefore that's OPT.
So that's just a
very quick sketch.
If you're interested,
check out the paper.
That's unfortunately all we
know what to do with Wilber 2.
But there's this
other bound, Wilber 1,
which seems less good yet we
can do a lot more with it.
So let me go to that.
It's a lot easier to analyze
algorithms with respect
to Wilber 1.
What's Wilber 1?
We're going to fix something
called a lower bound tree.
I'm going to call it
because it's basically
going to be a perfect
binary tree on my keys.
This tree never changes.
That's why I say fix.
It is not the binary search
tree you're looking for.
tree that you're interested in.
It's just a thing
to think about.
Now, for each node
of that tree--
let's look at this node,
I'll give the node a name, y.
So here's y.
There's the left subtree
of y, and there's
the right subtree of y.
These are a bunch of keys.
There's keys that
are to the left of y.
There's keys to the right of y.
There's keys
outside the subtree.
We're going to ignore those.
I want to look at the accesses
to these keys and accesses
to these keys and see
how many times do I
switch between left and right.
So count the number
of alternations--
so very similar in
spirit to Wilber 2,
it's just relative
to this weird tree,
which is kind of arbitrary--
in the access sequence--
which is x1 up to xn--
between left and
right subtrees of y
So we're going to ignore
accesses to y itself.
We're going to ignore
accesses to keys outside of y.
Just look at how many times
do I switch between x and y.
That's a lower bound.
That's the claim.
It's a lower bound
for the same reason
we use the independent
rectangle lower bound.
And the claim is, if you
look at these alternations,
draw the corresponding
rectangles--
so over here, we
had a vertical line
which corresponded to the key,
and we see how many times do we
cross the line.
Basically, the same thing
over here except now
there's one big vertical line
that corresponds to the root
node, then there's some
vertical lines that
correspond to this
node and this node,
and you're interested
in the access sequence.
How many times-- let's do some
kind of access sequence like
this--
these are our points--
and you just look at what
lines are you crossing.
So like this crosses
the big line.
So that's going to be one
alternation between left
and right here.
Here's another alternation
between left and right.
Here is another alternation
Here's another alternation
between left and right.
And one more.
So for the big line,
for the root node,
that's how many times you
cross between left and right
relative to the root.
Then, for the left
subtree the root,
there's one crossing here.
There is one crossing
here, one crossing here.
These are touching, but
they're not satisfied.
So it's OK.
The claim is all these
rectangles will be independent.
Again, I won't prove that
formally, but it's true.
OK?
Rough sketch.
So that's Wilber 1.
It's, again, an independent
rectangle lower bound.
It's a little weird because
it depends on this tree.
You could choose it to
be a nice perfect tree.
be a different tree.
You'll get a different
lower bound each time.
So of course, you take
the max over all trees.
That will give you the
biggest Wilber 1 lower bound.
We don't know much about that
I guess you could ask the
following open question.
Is it true that for
every access sequence
there exists a tree p such
that Wilber 1 is theta OPT?
Or is theta Wilber
2 or something?
Wilber 2 is a single quantity.
You compute it.
It gives you a bound.
Wilber 1, it depends on this p.
Maybe if you choose the
best p for your sequence
you get the right answer.
But it's definitely the case
that Wilber 1 for a fixed p
is not the right answer.
I recall that's easy to prove.
Well, maybe we'll
come back to that.
Yeah, question?
AUDIENCE: So how
do you construct
this lower bound tree?
Like, is it just--
ERIK DEMAINE: I'll tell you
what we're going to use--
the question is how
do we construct p.
You can make it
whatever you want.
What we're going to use
is the perfect tree,
which is sort of unique.
It's kind of arbitrary,
but it works.
It has the property that
its height is log n.
That's all we need.
We're going to use that
to get tango trees.
Other questions?
All right.
Let me briefly mention
a fun access sequence.
You may recognize this sequence.
This would be in-order
traversal in binary.
But if I take
these bit sequences
and read them backwards, then
I get 0, 4, 2, 6, 1, 5, 3, 7.
This is the number 0
through 7 in a funny order.
It's called the bit
reversal sequence.
If you access 0, 4, 2, 6, 1, 5,
3, 7 in a perfect binary tree,
it maximizes Wilber 1.
So in-order traversal--
0, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Ignore 7.
There's not 7 in this tree.
I do 0, 4--
if you look at the
root, alternate left,
right, left, right, left, right.
Because the high-order bit
is switching every time,
and so whether I go to
the left of the tree here
or the right of the tree,
it's switching every time.
And also, if you
look in any subtree,
like when I'm accessing things
within the subtree of one,
it alternates 0, too.
It's too small a tree to
really see that happening,
but it's true.
And so, if you do
this for k bits,
n equals 2 to the k roughly.
And Wilber 1, the
lower bound, is
log n per [INAUDIBLE] because
the every access alternates.
So if you look at
a subtree, whatever
the size of that
subtree is, that's
how many alternations there are.
And so, number of
alternations is theta n log n
because it's the sum over all
nodes of their subtree sizes.
And so OPT is theta n log n.
We know we can achieve n log n--
this is to do n accesses--
we know we can n log n with
a red-black tree or whatever,
but there's actually
a lower bound of n log
n, meaning all
binary search trees--
if you're given this
access sequence,
doesn't matter what you're
doing-- you have to pay
n log n.
It's kind of cool.
A little side effect--
that's Wilber's paper ended.
It's like, hey, cool, can
find one access sequence that
is bad for everybody.
But now we're going
to use Wilber 1
to get one binary search
tree that's pretty
good for all access sequences.
Pretty good meaning within a
log log n factor of optimal.
And this is tango
trees, which would
be log log n competitive
online binary search trees.
Why are they called tango trees?
People made up all sorts of
reasons, but I can tell you--
because I was there--
they were invented mostly
on a flight from New York
to Buenos Aires, which
is the center of tango.
I bought this T-shirt
I think the day after.
And then that week,
we wrote the paper,
and that was tango trees.
So no particular reason,
but it sounds good.
Always good to have a cool name.
So the secret is revealed.
The true meaning of tango trees
is nothing, but you we'll see.
So how do they work?
It's very simple.
Basically, we take Wilber
1 and we simulate it.
So let me be more precise.
There's one key idea, which
is to look at the preferred
child of a node.
I'm going to say the
preferred child is left.
Let's see, node y in p.
It's left if we accessed some
node in the left subtree of y
most recently.
It's the right
child if we accessed
something in the right
subtree most recently.
So we're just looking at left
and right subtree accesses,
what was most recent?
There is a special case
in the beginning, which
is you don't have a preferred
child because you haven't
accessed either
left or right yet.
So this is if no access
to the left or right yet.
So that just happens
in the beginning.
Once you've touched
everything, everybody
will have a left or
right preferred child.
So this is just what was
your most recent child.
This is like a parent
with a very short memory.
Just whichever child I
most recently talked to,
that is my preferred
child at the moment.
It's kind of like
I don't know when
you're going to job interviews.
You know, the most
recent interview
is the one you remember
most fondly and so, ah,
you like that one the
best independent of which
is the coolest.
So let me draw a picture.
And I guess I'm going
to draw a big picture--
my favorite-- a perfectly
balanced binary search tree
with eight leaves.
And so now, suppose that every
node has a preferred child.
Let's say they all do
just because it makes
a more interesting picture.
I'm going to draw that
with a big fat arrow.
And now, what does that do?
It decomposes our tree.
This is the perfect tree. p is
going to be perfectly balanced,
log n height.
It could be any
log n height tree,
but we'll make it perfect.
And it decomposes
that tree into paths.
And there's a path here.
You just keep following parent
pointers, you get a path--
not parent pointers,
preferred pointers.
It's also true if you follow
parent pointers you get a path,
but they'll overlap each other.
You follow preferred
child pointers,
you get non-overlapping paths.
There they are.
We also get these singleton
paths at the leaves.
Some of the leaves are
in singleton paths.
These are called
preferred paths.
Why do I care?
So this tells me the most
recently accessed element
was somebody on this path.
I don't quite know who.
It could have been this
one, and that would say,
OK, this is the most
recent direction
we went through all of them.
Let's say it's that one.
Now suppose I access this node.
What does that tell me?
Well, if I most recently
accessed left here
and now I'm accessing the
right, if you look at this node,
the Wilber 1 bound goes up by 1.
Because I just accessed left.
Now I accessed right.
Also, if I access this node,
this guy, his Wilber 1 bound
goes up by 1 because now
he's going to the right,
whereas last time
he went to the left.
Also, this node previously
went to the right
and went to the left.
So Wilber 1 went up
because of this edge,
and it went up
because of this edge.
In general, following
non-preferred edges,
I can pay for because
Wilber 1 goes up by 1
every time I use a
non-preferred edge.
This is another way to
state the Wilber 1 bound.
This is the cool thing.
As long as I can go
through a path quickly--
ideally, if I could do
it in constant time,
this would be a
dynamically-optimal binary
search tree.
If I could instantly transport
to where I need to go on a path
and then jump off the
path to the next path,
that I can pay for--
I can spend constant
time to do that--
then I'd be OK.
I'm not going to be able
to do it in constant time,
but I'm going to be able
to do it log log n time.
I'm going to be able to jump
through a path in log log n
time, and then jump--
figure out where I need
to diverge from the path
because maybe I'm
accessing this guy.
Jump to the next path.
Do that in log log n time.
I've got to update
the path structure
because now the preferred
child is to the right.
It used to be to the left.
So I've got to do something that
will only cost log log n time.
If I can do that, the lower
bound is the number of edges.
The upper bound is the
number of non-preferred edges
times log log n.
So we get a lower
bound Wilber 1,
which is going to be
equal to the number
of non-preferred edges.
And we're going to
get an upper bound
through tango trees,
which is going
to be order number of
non-preferred edges times
log log n.
OK.
Why is it log log n?
Because each of these paths
has length only log n.
So put them in a balanced
binary search tree,
and it has height log log n.
So take these paths,
squish them into a tree--
it's hard, I don't know
which way you're squishing.
It says log n depth.
It's a path.
I'm going to fold
it into a tree.
So it has height only log log n.
Then I can jump around
it in log log n time.
That's the idea
with tango trees.
You're basically done.
A few details in how they work.
I don't want to spend
too much time on them,
but let's go through
some of them.
So we're going to store
each preferred path
as an auxiliary
tree, which is just--
I don't know-- a
red-black tree, say.
What is the red-black
tree sorted by?
I don't have a choice.
Whatever I do has to
be a binary search
tree among the original keys.
So if I take these items
and I just throw them
into a red-black tree, they
will be sorted by whatever
their x-coordinate is.
So this is the max,
this is the min.
This is somewhere in between.
This is to the left of that.
So the order is a little weird.
I'd really like to store
them sorted by depth,
but I can't do that.
They are sorted by
their key values.
Now, what do I need to do
with these auxiliary trees?
I mean, the basic thing
I do is a search, right?
I'm searching for a key.
It's a binary search tree,
so I can still do a search.
I can figure out this
tree gets represented
as something more like this.
That would be a nicely balanced
version of these four nodes.
So if I called them, I
don't know, a, b, c, d.
That's their sorted order.
It's going to be a, b, c, d.
That's also their
sorted order over here.
So if I search for my
key, I'll figure out, oh,
do I fall off here, here,
here, here, or here?
Now, each of those
corresponds to another path
I need to visit.
So if I fall off
the left side of a,
then I should have a
pointer to this structure.
If I fall off the--
I guess these two are empty.
Those correspond to
these two places.
If I fall off here, the right
side of c, which is now here,
this is going to be a
pointer to my new structure
which corresponds to this one.
And then this one is going to
correspond to all this stuff--
well, in particular this one.
It's a little hard to draw this
picture, but you get the idea.
You just rebalance
each of these things.
Keep that the pointers
between the preferred paths
just as they were.
This is uniquely defined
how to do this because it's
a binary search tree.
So leaves point to other--
let's call them child
auxiliary trees.
It uniquely defines
which ones they
have to point to in
order to still navigate
the whole structure.
So it's a weird way of
rebalancing your tree.
And the point is each of these
red-black trees has height log
log n because the number of
nodes in it is only log n.
And that gives us the bound.
Now, key thing to think about is
what happens when you change--
I said I have to
be able to achieve
number of non-preferred
edges times log log n.
So fine.
I do a log log n search in here.
Maybe I decide I
have to go off here.
Then I do a log log
n search in here.
And then maybe I
have to go this way.
So number of
non-preferred edges was 2.
I did two, maybe three searches.
Fine.
It's going to be number
of non-preferred edges
plus 1 time log log n.
No big deal.
Now I have to update.
Now this is the preferred
edge from the root,
and this is the preferred
edge from this node.
How do I update preferred edges?
That's something to think about.
So I've got a path represented
by a red-black tree.
And now I fall off here, and
there's another path here.
I need to convert this into
a path that goes like this
and then does this.
And separately, a
path that does this.
That's the new version.
How do I do that?
Conceptually, it's
pretty simple.
I want to cut the path here
and then rejoin along there,
like that.
So conceptually, if things
were stored by depth,
this is what we'd call a
split and a concatenate.
You should know this from
regular binary search trees.
This is a standard exercise
for red-black trees.
Given a query, x, you can
cut this tree into two halves
and get two red-black trees,
which represent everything
to the left of x and
everything to the right of x.
Similarly, given
two trees that are
sorted like this where
all the elements are
less than all the
elements over here,
I can concatenate them
into one red-black tree.
And all of these
take log n time,
where n is the number of nodes.
Here, that would
be log log n time.
In this world, it's
not quite so simple
because things are
not sorted by depth.
They're sorted by key value.
But it's not so bad.
Because, if you look at some
path and you want to say,
OK, I want everything
that's below this key value
or something, then that's
the same as saying,
well, take everything that is
within this interval of keys.
So it's strictly
between here and here.
Let me redraw this slightly.
So if you look at the nodes
of depth greater than d,
I want to cut off
everybody that's
deeper than a
particular spot in order
to do this kind of change.
These are equal to nodes
in subtree of that.
So let me give it a name.
Let's say I want to cut here.
So I'm going to
look at this node y.
This is nodes in
the subtree of y.
All of the nodes
that are below y
are obviously going to have
smaller depth than that path.
This is nodes in a path.
And nodes in a subtree
are equal to nodes
with keys in the
min of that subtree
to the max of that tree.
It's an interval.
So what do I do?
I split at min of y.
I split at max of y.
That gives me the interval.
So here's the picture.
I have a tree.
I want to cut out this
interval of nodes.
This is like range
queries kind of in 1D.
So I split here.
I split here.
What I will have
are the things I
care about, the things
to the left of it
and the things to
the right of it.
What I wanted was this
and everything else.
How do I do that?
I concatenate-- this is y.
This is in the interval
min of y to max of y.
So I wanted those guys.
Those are the nodes
that are deeper than d.
I also want the nodes
all together that
are less deep than d.
That's these nodes
and these nodes.
So I concatenate
these together, get
one big tree that represents
things with depth less than d.
These are the things of
depth greater than d.
OK?
So I do two splits,
one concatenate,
and that simulates this
kind of cut operation.
Similarly, if I want to
do a joint operation,
it's a constant number of splits
and concatenates, and I'm done.
Just dealing with the fact that
things are in the wrong order
here, but it's not so bad.
One more thing, which is--
I basically described
the overall structure
as a tree of auxiliary trees.
In reality, we're in the
binary search tree model.
We can only have one tree.
Not so hard, though.
I mean, basically,
you want one tree that
represents lots of trees that
are kind of pasted together.
So to do that, you
just mark each node
that transitions from
one tree to the next.
So each node will say, I am the
root of a new auxiliary tree
or just say, no, I'm part
of the same auxiliary tree
as my parent.
And then you have to
define these kinds of split
and concatenate operations in
this setting where you have
a tree embedded inside a tree.
But you just ignore
all the nodes
that are claimed to be
part of another tree.
Just pretend they weren't
there, and it works.
So a little hand-wavy there, but
it's kind of a tedious detail.
You can stick all these
trees into one tree
just by marking these roots.
And that's tango trees.
I already spoiled the climax,
which is this log log n thing,
but it's pretty obvious
how to get there.
It's just a lot of
details to actually do it.
We're just taking
the Wilber 1 bound,
recasting it in terms of
this preferred path thing
where it's just the
non-preferred edges.
Or the non-preferred edges
are what Wilber 1 counts,
and so we can afford
to spend log log n
time for each of them.
And the paths themselves
only have log n nodes,
so you can search through them
in log log n time pretty easy.
This also shows you
why Wilber 1 is not
a good bound with a fixed tree.
Because here are log n nodes.
I can just sit there all day
bouncing around all of them
in random order.
I'm definitely going to need
log log n time to access them,
but Wilber 1 is not
changing at all.
So Wilber 1 stays
constant, like 0.
I had to warm it up, but
after I test everything,
I can just sit there and bounce
around these guys randomly.
I've got to spend log
log n time to do that,
but Wilber 1 doesn't
justify it for me.
Wilber 2 will go up, but
Wilber 1 with this tree?
It's kind of lame.
So this is the best
tango trees could
hope to do using Wilber 1.
I would guess that tango
trees are a log log
factor away from optimal, though
we don't know that for sure.
But greedy we're still
pretty sure is good.
It should be a constant
factor away from optimal.
So I want to talk a
little bit about that.
There's one thing
on this outline
we haven't talked about.
We did independent rectangles.
We did Wilber 1 and 2.
We saw applications of them
in particular tango trees.
One thing we haven't
done is Signed Greedy.
So let's do Signed Greedy.
Still left here is we
have two ways to choose
rectangles,
independent rectangles.
They're different.
It would be kind of nice
to know what the best
way to choose rectangles is.
And we actually know that--
Signed Greedy.
So there's two kinds
of Signed Greedy.
There's the plus sign
greedy, and there's
the minus sign greedy.
How does plus greedy work?
It's the same as
greedy, you just
only look at plus rectangles.
Remember plus rectangles
and minus rectangles.
So let's look at our
favorite example here.
With greedy, I would sweep
up, and every rectangle that
was unsatisfied, I
would satisfy it.
Now I'm going to ignore
minus rectangles,
only look at plus rectangles.
So I see this rectangle,
and I say, oh, I
don't care because
that's a minus rectangle.
Then I see this
one and this one.
I say, oh, those
are plus rectangles.
So I'm going to
add a point here.
I'm going to add a point here.
Then I go up to here.
I see this rectangle,
which is a plus rectangle.
That's bad.
So I've got to add a point.
I see this minus rectangle
I don't care about.
This is plus greedy.
It does not satisfy the set.
This rectangle
never got satisfied.
But it plus satisfies the set.
If I do plus greedy, it
will be plus satisfied.
Every rectangle you draw
here, if it's plus rectangle,
it's got another point in it.
What's kind of nice,
also, is if you actually
draw the rectangles
you are satisfying--
maybe I'm use another color.
There was one rectangle here.
And there was one
rectangle here.
That's a little awkward
because they're not
on the original points.
So I can change
them a little bit,
maybe move this one down to here
and move this one over to here.
You could say that
those rectangles
came from those points.
Then this is a set of
independent rectangles
on the original points.
Maybe not totally
obvious, but plus greedy
always gives an independent
set of plus rectangles.
So it's a lower bound.
It's not an upper bound because
it's not satisfying the point
set, but it's a lower bound.
I claim it's a very
good lower bound.
It by itself might
not be great, but you
have to consider both of them.
So theorem is if I take the
max of plus greedy and minus
greedy--
each of them is lower
bound, so the max
is a lower bound on optimal--
then this is within
a constant factor
of the biggest possible
independent rectangle lower
bound.
And so this is
the way you should
choose independent rectangles.
Run plus greedy.
Run minus greedy.
Take the best of the two.
That will always be
within a constant factor
of the best independent set
of rectangles, factors like 4
or something in the worst case.
So let me prove this to you.
It's a kind of a weird argument.
I'm going to define
a new quantity.
Let's call this OPT x, I guess.
It's sort of like if you
consider plus rectangles
separately from minus
rectangles, which
is what we're doing.
So I would like a point set--
first, I'd like a plus
satisfying point set,
and then I'd also like a
minus satisfying point set.
And then I take their union.
And I say the cost of that pair
of plus satisfying and minus
satisfying is the
size of the union.
So I get a bonus point if
they happen to overlap.
Not a big deal,
just a factor of 2.
So this is not a core
concept, but it turns out
to be basically what we
were doing over here.
Let me give you a sequence
of crazy inequalities.
First one is that this
OPT thing is greater than
or equal to size of the input.
Each of these inequalities
is totally obvious,
but the conclusion
is kind of crazy.
The independent rectangle
lower bound, which we proved,
says that if you look at
plus satisfying things that's
going to be at least
size of the input
plus the max number of
independent rectangles.
If you look at the
minus satisfying things,
that's also going to be
at least size of the input
plus maximum number of minus
independent rectangles.
So we already proved this.
That, if you look
at this union, it's
going to be at least the
size of the input plus half
the overall max.
So that's what we proved
at the beginning a lecture.
Now, this is the best way to
use independent rectangles.
This kind of Signed
Greedy, which
is the max of the
two signs, is a way
to find independent rectangles.
So it's only going to be worse.
It's going to be smaller.
So we can say is greater
than or equal to half
the max of plus greedy
and minus greedy.
This was the max.
So this is another way to do
it, so it must be smaller.
Now, greedy computes a
plus satisfying assignment.
So I could say, well, if you
looked at the optimal plus
satisfying assignment--
this is something we defined
at the beginning of lecture--
and the optimal minus
satisfying assignment, that's
only going to be smaller
than greedy because greedy
is an algorithm for
solving OPT plus.
It can't be better
than the optimum.
Greedy again has to be
bigger than the optimum.
Now I just want to turn
this max into a plus
because the max is always
at least the average.
So if I take the average, which
turns it into 1/4 OPT plus
plus OPT minus.
Then that holds.
You turn the max into a plus.
If I look at the
optimal plus satisfying
plus the optimal
minus satisfying,
that's only going to be
bigger than this thing
because this can only
save like a factor of 2
or whatever over
just adding them up.
I don't even need to
factor of 2 thing.
I just need that
if you add them up,
that's only going to be
worse than just counting them
as the union.
So we get what I
call a sandwich.
On the one side, we have OPT x.
On the other side,
we have 1/4 OPT x.
I really don't care
about OPT x personally.
I mean, it's kind of interesting
to see that it's here.
But the point is these are
within a constant factor.
Therefore, all of
these things in between
are within a constant
factor of each other.
So in particular, this thing,
max of the two greedys,
is within a constant
factor of this thing.
This is the independent
rectangle lower bound,
the best one.
It also tells you that
OPT x is basically
what we're computing here.
So this is weird.
I'm going to draw one
more picture, which
is greedy versus Signed Greedy.
Remember greedy
from last lecture.
Greedy says, look, I'm going
to fix plus rectangles,
and I'm going to fix
minus rectangles.
It does them both
at the same time.
Signed Greedy says,
look, I'm going
to do the plus
rectangles separately,
and then I'm going to the
minus rectangles separately,
and then add them up or take
the union or take the max.
It doesn't matter.
It's a constant factor.
Just add them separately.
This one is an upper bound.
It is a binary search tree.
This thing is a lower bound.
All binary search trees
must take at least this.
Are they equal up
to constant factors?
We don't know.
That's the big question.
They look almost identical.
But what greedy has to deal with
is sort of the interrelations.
When I fix some
plus rectangles, I
might get new minus rectangles
that I have to fix with greedy.
Signed Greedy doesn't
have to deal with that.
It's just the plus rectangles.
They might make more
plus rectangles,
but that's all I
have to deal with.
It doesn't deal
with the interaction
between plus and
minus rectangles.
Seems like the interaction
kind of fades away
as a geometric series.
And therefore, these
things are the same
up to constant factors.
But we have no
way to prove that.
It could be the interaction
blows you out of the water
somehow.
That's the best we know
for dynamic optimality.
Maybe next time I teach this
class we'll have a final answer
and it'll be constant, but
that's where we are today.